مدينه كان الحياه توقفت فيها هكذا تبدو
مدينه باخمود وقد غادرها معظم اهلها
اصوات القصف لا تكاد تتوقف تذكره بان تم
معارك طاحنه تدور على مشارف هذه المدينه
والاسواقه ومرافق البنيه التحتيه ولم
تستثني حتى ملعبها الرياضيه الرئيسي
لاحق الدمار بالجسور التي تربط شطرين
المدينه وهو ما يجبر كثيرا من بقي من
سكانها على تجشم عناء رحله يوميه محفوفه
بالمخاطر للحصول على بعض المساعدات
الانسانيه من المؤسسات الاغاثيه التي تجرؤ
على دخول المدينه برشلونه
في هذه الظروف لم تجد الينا بددا من اعداد
الطعامها على الحطب ترفض مغادره مدينتها
بخمود وترفض الحديث للكاميرا انها لا تريد
ان تتحول الى لاجئتان في هذه السن من
حياتها التقينا اندريه وزوجته الذين خرجان
لتفقد الشقق من غادر المدينه من اصدقائهما
ماذا يمكنني ان اقول نعيش وسط اصوات
الانفجارات المرعبه ولدت هنا واريد ان
اموت هنا
توصف جبهه مدينه بخمود بانها اعنف جبهات
القتال في مقاطعه دونيتس الا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تؤكد قدرتها على سد
المحاولات الروسيه المتكرره لاقتحام
المدينه من ثلاثه محاور وقد غدد لا تبعد
عنها سوى نحوي ثلاثه كيلومترات
منذ نحوي اربعه اشهر والقوات الروسيه
تحاول السيطره على مدينه بخمود
الاستراتيجيه لفتح الطريق امامها
تورس المدينهتين
تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
الدونات